and that's what it was when uh he was
here like I just felt like I couldn't
talk to him because he was just like
and it's like I hate having
conversations with people that don't go
into things in good faith because even
if you're correct and you don't let the
other person speak then it just becomes
it's no longer a conversation it's more
like you think you're better than the
other person and whatever you say is
Gospel yeah well even when he was here I
was talking about how you shouldn't get
divorced over chores and then he just
starts going personal he's like you
sound like a kid right now have you ever
been in a serious relation like like
this this this this and this and then
I'm like okay well what does it have to
do with what I said